good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Thursday day
like a teen in quarantine I've truly
lost count but it doesn't matter because
we're here to provide you with
entertainment with positivity with
radiance with elegance and light as much
as we can I'm so [ __ ] over this
nonsense no by the way I'm over life in
quarantine
I really miss life like I miss drink it
like Ben's birthday's tomorrow and it's
really setting in how like he's not
having a birthday let out you didn't
even like acknowledge that it's his
birthday it's too sad you should just
like postpone the day deal with it later
we have a zoom happy hour planned like a
I think that's the extent of the
celebrations I got some candles but I
went to the grocery store and couldn't
find a cake so I didn't get him a
present either so yeah that's the status
of the birthday and just feel free to
send him wishes because that stuff
matters to him you know I don't think
there's anything sadder than a zoom
happy hour and I just say and I just
refused to participate it what do you
have to tomorrow really yeah okay I
guess when it's with like the Steen's
and it's fine well it's like a big one
is other people zoom happy hours I'm
just like you know who's always on a
zoom happy hour go this match well I've
been on zoom I don't know I think
branding it as a zoom happy hour is
really lame like but then when you're on
it you're like oh it really is nice to
talk to every yeah and I've been on like
zoom not happy hours but you know nine
o'clock everyone's like hey you want to
get on zoom and play a game drink a
little bit like those are fun but when
they're organized by like your coworkers
and it's at five o'clock Brandi that's
like a happy hour branding is everything
and I think that that's lame I would
agree yes so I guess I'll see you
tomorrow night on zoom happy hour but
yellow is pretty good for it's good for
recording an episode of the redheads
yesterday we recorded our newest episode
of the redheads book club talking about
the latest book nothing to see here it
was nice to get all the girls on the
show we obviously had to do it remotely
because we are all social distancing and
because Becky has corona so maybe you
want to hear about how she's doing tune
in to the redheads just like a little
click tape but it was a fun episode and
you're able
here all of us and it's just a fun thing
how's the audio really it's I mean
here's the thing it's not great but you
can hear what we're saying you know I
think in the age of Corona podcast
listeners have severely lowered their
standards when it comes to popular idea
because everyone aside from us is
recording remotely because they're not
quarantined with their podcast partners
yes so it really wasn't so bad honestly
it was great to catch up with the girls
and even though we were recording a
podcast like I guess we were technically
on his oom happy hour I didn't have a
cocktail but I did have a diet dr.
pepper and and it did fishermen at my
feet
god forbid but he just rolled over did
you um did anyone else have a drink no I
mean we were working you know what it
referred them [ __ ]
I know zoom happy hours are lame but
there's something about being on your
computer with other people that they're
any having a drink that momentarily
makes you forget that you're in your
house alone and the second that the zoom
ends and you're just like drunk in your
house like that's the worst yeah like
what it's over and it's like time for
bed you have to go back to work tomorrow
like that that is so treacherous it's
enough to make you not get on the zoom
happy hour at all yeah I haven't
experienced that but that actually
sounds really sad it's like when people
just start dropping off like one by one
and then it's like three people left in
the gameís categories two people left
and then you gotta go it's so depressing
damn okay well it didn't it hasn't
gotten there for me yet I still haven't
had a drink in quarantine that crazy I'm
saving that sensation for like a really
dark day you know it's coming but in the
meantime I've been reading so much we do
this thing on the redheads where we talk
about all the books that we've read in
the past month and like then I make a
little cute um social card with all the
books in our ratings and for mine this
month I had to make two cards because if
they didn't all fit on one card and you
know what all the books I read I didn't
have any fives like they were all kind
of shitty so oh that's so sad but then
Snitch chose her book it next month and
Hoover no not Colleen Hoover Renee Carly
no next month is snitches choice so
we're gonna get like some good like
rom-com why a bi it's a true snitches
choice it's a true snitches choice so
make sure you're catching up with the
redheads I feel like joining a book club
podcast is their the best thing you
could do dirt and Quarantine like I'm so
glad that we launched this before
quarantine yeah also if you're looking
for more content there's a brand new
episode of maternity leg it's super long
Olivia's doing a bunch of stuff on
pregnancy in quarantine and Corona
and she's a doctor come on and certain
like official questions about like the
correlation between being pregnant and
extra precautions you could be taking so
it's really every like hypochondriacs
dream so head over to Spotify and iTunes
for that yeah there are so many
questions are on current IRS and
pregnancy and we asked we scratch we
scratch the surface with dr. Burks but
Olivia really goes beneath the surface
and I think it's a great episode so head
on over there she's working ot I'm
maternity live but we knew she was and
there's really not else she like it has
to do besides like work from home but
yes she really is giving it her all and
I think they're cultivating quite a
community on the maternity livers
Facebook group if you're pregnant or you
just like want to be a part of the
podcast group its maternity livers Li B
ers and yeah there's tons of new
episodes new mood with Lauren Elizabeth
Newmarket Joseph's new snatchler so tons
of episodes to get you through the
weekend because we are not doing an
episode tomorrow Jackie I was going to
take the day off and like try and plan
something for Ben on Friday so I
preemptively took this Friday off and
then it turns out I can do it - we're
going to Vegas yeah but then I came back
and I'm like oh and then I was like
we'll do the show Friday but then I'm
like you know what let me try and you
know do something nice and I
legitimately couldn't figure out
anything to do nice like I couldn't even
find a decoration store that was open
like no balloon saloon what if you get
in the car and go for a nice Drive oh
right like drive up the Hudson a little
sell the action wow that's a fabulous
idea if it's a beautiful day like today
like that sounds heavenly oh my god okay
by the way done yeah that's a great
place to quarantine in a car and Ben
actually has a car yeah okay oh my god
that's a fabulous idea okay so that's
what I'm doing tomorrow and then another
programming update is that in the next
couple weeks we have decided to do shows
only Monday Wednesday Friday for a
multitude of reasons one there's like
not enough news to report every single
day and you mostly to limit the amount
that we are going outside right we're
super super careful and hyper aware and
are meticulous in how we get to what the
studio the studio is like around the
corner from here right without giving
away too much about where we live we are
so careful but we just want to minimize
the amount that we are exposing
ourselves and also there's not that much
to talk about every day so Monday
Wednesday Friday that will give us
enough time to watch terrible movies in
the in between each week yes I had a
terrible movie
I think I'm like angry today because I
woke up on my own before my alarm this
morning an hour before my alarm and I
was just up and I already decided I
wasn't gonna finish dinner fresh marks I
stopped in the middle but then I was up
an hour before and I knew that you
finished it and like I have to do my
homework I'm such a teacher's pet yeah
so I put it on and it absolutely set me
on the wrong foot but for the day it's
the worst movie I ever saw ever everyone
who participated in that movie who made
sure that it's odd light of day needs to
be arrested they should be ashamed no
they need to be arrested they are a
disgrace to the to the the art of acting
they need to be arrested for stealing my
time yep and my joy and my patience I'm
so angry we'll dive into it as well as
give our assignment for the weekend
which I think we spoke about earlier you
guys are really gonna like and yeah we
just have fast five and that's pretty
MEA three you can't banter pom pearls
because I do actually watch yet and I
have a lot of thoughts me too I wrote
them all down great can't did it did the
episode trigger you because it was all
about pranking um why would that trigger
me because I hate we hate prey I do hate
pranks but you know what it's so funny
like my reaction to both the pranks was
so different because like I like Jackson
I hate sad of all like I agreed with
Jackson what an annoying [ __ ] prank
like we're adults like someone has to
clean that up keeping the house it's
like such it's just so immature but then
like Jackson Randall's prank was so next
level but I hate toms and I'm also I'm
like yeah get it oh no totally I agree
and I you know it I don't even think I'm
being biased like Tom's prank sucks
Jackson Randall are everything of the
sort and then people's reactions to the
prank and Brian Moylan did you read his
yes it was I think they're always
fabulous but to me sometimes I can't
really put to words like why something
bothered me or why I think someone's
acting insane but he's so poignant Lee
describes it and like even Ariana having
like we know we'll talk about it we'll
talk about it up we'll talk about let me
recap at the end of the show so before
that let us get into the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and that's true Jackie but you know I
feel like it's really important during
these quarantine times to remind
everyone about a sponsor called talk
space we all have something that we want
to change about ourselves whether it's
spending too much time on social media
are wanting to start a new hobby but if
you're like us like most people taking
action can feel impossible without the
right support we're all busy and
sometimes you you could think you know
the money for that and the time for that
but talk space online therapy is the
most convenient and affordable way to
make lasting change in your life without
with the support of a licensed therapist
send you licensed therapists text
texts audio picture or video messages
from your phone or computer whenever you
need to even if it's on the way to work
you don't have to make appointments or
deal with extra commutes everything
happens within talk space secure
platform on your schedule they match you
with a licensed therapist based on your
needs and preferences they have
thousands of licensed therapists trained
in over 40 specialties so if you have
something specific you want to work on
they will find someone right for you and
I think in the age of quarantine
probably something people aren't able to
do is go to sessions with their
therapist hmm and whether you had a
therapist before after I feel like now's
a perfect time to get on talk space
because it can be so isolating being in
quarantine and if you're quarantined
with someone you don't like like it can
be super toxic and having just an outlet
is fabulous fabulous talk space they
match you with advice and therapists
once your match you can begin therapy
the same exact day many people think
therapy is just about analyzing
analyzing dreams are digging into
painful memories and that can be
powerful but it's also a great tool for
developing coping skills dealing with
stress and getting the accountability
you need to achieve your goals the
bottom line is that life can be hard and
talk space wants to give you more to
this wants to give more of us the
support we need at a price we can afford
as a listener of his podcast you can get
$100 off your first month on talk space
to match with your perfect therapist go
to talk space calm or download the app
make sure you use the code toast TOA st
to get $100 off your first month and
show your support for the show that's
toast TOA st and the link is talk space
comm thank you talk space for sponsoring
this episode love it honestly a really
pertinent sponsor these current of times
okay first story of the day is the few
that absolutely no one asked for but i
know correction i definitely ask for it
but you know what like we are actually
grateful for it's really the big story
of the day two people whose name i never
thought i would say in the same sentence
but i think are also neighbors you know
they're inextricably linked Mason Disick
and Jeffrey star are going head to head
after Mason called Geoffrey star
spoiled aaf as [ __ ] spoiled as [ __ ] on
his lie which I thought he got his
Instagram taken away yeah I thought so
too I think they just like keep popping
up I saw Courtney diddle
I've where she like explained that Mason
never had an Instagram he doesn't even
have a phone but he does have an iPad in
the computer for school and he made it
himself a little instant how old is he
unclear like how old our kids now when
they get their phones I think I got a
phone in the fourth grade but I don't
think I would have gotten it if it
weren't for 911 like 911 made all these
parents like give their phones give
their kids phones yeah okay some
emergency I got mine in the fifth grade
that's when I'm gonna give my kids
phones yeah I think so too what grade is
Mason in you think I know and how old
are you when you're in the fourth grade
well you were 14 no I wasn't in when I
was in the fourth grade it was 2004
that's my little trick I so that you
were 10 okay I was 10
oh so you know what makes it isn't Mike
Agri might actually be in the 4th or 5th
grade yeah but he doesn't have a phone
cord did Mason Disick is either 30 years
old or 3 like I can't decide he's
literally Scott did it I just want to
say like when and everyone's parenting
and they're not here to judge anyone's
parenting but I feel like when you
restrict kids from being on social media
but they obviously want to be on it they
like rebel and do [ __ ] livestreams
talking about their family yeah it's
crazy but then Jeffrey star took to
Twitter when he deleted it just
explained himself he said I had $500 in
my bank account six years ago maybe he's
confused with his own privilege versus
mine being self-made hopefully his
father can educate him soon he deleted
it shortly thereafter because I when I
went to go find it's a screenshot and
put on our Instagram and if you're
looking for a clip of Mason calling him
spoiled it's on our Instagram at the
morning toast and I couldn't find his
tweet on Twitter so we obviously deleted
it because why is he beating with the 12
year old mm-hmm but the I mean I don't
like we can't talk about this without
you know addressing like the hypocrisy
literally like the face of spoil
children may sadistic like the oldest
Kardashian kid like literally didn't
last season he bite his nanny like
Penelope did you know what I mean like
they're the and by the way and they're
rich so it's not a big yeah but he
spoiled yeah no I 18 lies private it
seems as though he doesn't know the
definition of spoiled I think maybe what
he meant I think he doesn't know truly
what spoiled means and I know he meant
like it rich yeah like just extravagant
AF Adam because why wouldn't Mason
Disick let's think of like the roadmap
of people arguing between the
kardashian-jenner z-- and the stars like
Kylie and him don't really get along but
I don't think Mason was gonna go on his
lot to defend Kylie's honor you know him
Kim like do have a good relationship I
don't know how it even came up on his
life but I do think they all lived in
the same community so I'm sure he like
rides by Jeffrey's house on his bicycle
and he sees like all the spoiled things
going on and he assumes that he's
spoiled but he doesn't realize like that
he got those things for himself you know
no one gave them to him but yeah but I
don't think he's old enough to
understand like why being spoiled has
it's not it doesn't just mean having
things yeah I definitely agree with you
that there's a large misunderstanding
here as to what the word spoiled and I'm
gonna give him the benefit of the doubt
because he's 10 he's a kid he's 12
actually now that I remember I read a
tweet they said he was 12 okay cuz he's
12 you know by the way I don't think
there was any bad intent here I
definitely agree he 100% does not know
the meaning of spoiled yeah and I could
see out just a kid but think spoiled is
like yes glamorous extravagant extra
money yeah wealth totally yeah so
because the if he knows what it means
the hypocrisy and the lack of
self-awareness it's just yeah it's it's
startling yeah yeah yeah it's oh and his
use of AF was also just like kind of
weird honestly like I know he's totally
accepting out of bounds and doing these
lives and poppin off and like spilling
family and trade secrets but it's
everything that we need during this time
of course by the way I need to follow
him yeah but he's always like popping up
I'm different like burner again he's
like different cell phones hidden under
mattresses because Kourtney keeps taking
them away yes so you never you'll always
like miss alive even though James
Charles was commenting on I know weird
yeah maybe like Mason's gonna get big
into like the beauty guru community I
don't know if anyone's gonna be north oh
my god I can't have competition in the
fan I can't wait also new episode of
Kardashians tonight and the premiere of
Real Housewives of New York right I'm so
excited I guess we'll recap all of it on
Monday we could do a patriotic episode
recapping the episodes they'll be good
yeah um yeah there's good TV Thursday's
had become like a hot night in
television when they were virtually
irrelevant before this I know but also
it's like there's no days of the week
right now so can they just be like
giving us hot like still no one has
stepped up to the plate content mine you
know what's so funny it's been three
weeks right and no one has stepped up to
the plate weeks ago you said I wish we
could just get the Real Housewives of
New York like to premiere now or
premiere the whole the whole season and
I think we thought like in three weeks
like this would all be over but now it's
in three weeks and Rio knees already
premiering and it's like we're not even
close to being out of this no I didn't
think it would be over but like we're
what have I been doing for the last
three weeks I've watched like literal
garbage like I just watched like a pile
of garbage like burn response is called
in here fresh Montella vision like I
could have been watching Roni no I know
it's so upsetting also you know I was
recently reading through our podcast
reviews which one should never do it's
really such a toxic it's like Reddit
honestly and someone literally left us a
one-star review because we say Mahoney
instead of Roni oh I did see that
can you believe like someone gonna go
out of their way to leave a one-star
review that's so many people I've seen
like a few podcast reviews like really
negative ones because people like are
taking umbrage with us that we'd like
Jax Taylor like yeah it's like a thing
that I've seen from like more than one
review that like the fact that we defend
Jax like were horrible people sorry I
know Jax he's my friend and I like him a
lot you defend your friends I also like
him on TV like sorry ya know I've always
liked it but it's called growth look it
up
okay next story ena Guardian quarantines
with a massive cocktail recipe okay I
just before you dive in ena you know I
don't okay I don't know if you guys are
realizing me and me this week but like I
don't pronounce anything correctly
really I said a million no but that's
like a difficult word everyone knows I
Nagar I pronounce everyone's names wrong
do you know the show all the time yes I
don't associate you with being like a
mispronunciation
okay I never thought of that but yeah it
might be true it is it's fine a garden
yeah because also even when like I know
what someone's name is like then
sometimes I'm worrying I'm getting it
wrong I just like get into my head too
much so then I just pronounce it
phonetically yeah I know
inna garden ina the Food Network Star
posted a video on how to make a massive
cocktail that is perfect for those
quarantined amid the corona virus
pandemic quote during these stressful
times it's really important to keep
traditions alive she said in the video
my favorite tradition is the cocktail
hour so I'm gonna make you my favorite
cosmopolitan and you probably have all
the ingredients right in your house
she's such a Carrie Bradshaw she used an
entire bottle of vodka mixed with mixed
with a large amount of Cointreau
probably so not going to cranberry juice
cocktail fresh lime juice which she then
mixed in a gigantic shaker before
pouring into a larger-than-life martini
glass
the whole video is iconic like the fact
that I mean you don't even think about
people like Ina Garten right I'd
quarantine me she's not corn but it's
like did she leave her house before
quarantine even or did she have that big
martini glass just in the house she
always like even on her show she doesn't
leave the Hampton clip said I've seen
like she has the Garten she lives in a
garden like she doesn't need she doesn't
need for anything sometimes her and
Jeffery go out to the farmers market or
you know to get some wine some good
cheese is some provolone they do leave
the house good they go to the local shop
I feel like she has like cows on her
estate and she can make her own cheese
and her own provolone you know what I
don't know the house that they show on
Barefoot Contessa Contessa is her actual
show but it's not really a state it's
just like a nice Hamptons beach house
yeah I feel like she's very
self-sufficient you know you know she
probably makes her own toilet in
farm-to-table yeah her entire what's the
word like oh that hotel we say that in
LA like totally sustainable yeah that's
her her house yes she like has a coop I
think makes her own compost really like
people now like who live on a farm right
now and have like a chicken coop living
their own eggs like no but they're
really the best suited for this
quarantine yeah sustainable completely
and Ina Garten is definitely she
definitely like she's definitely a
sustainable queen yebin like takes her
owners like use to sterilize for sure
for sure oh she takes Jefferies and it's
like we're judging now but when the
grocery stores run out and they're on
and hit up that chicken coop ya know and
she's like sewing together like her
quilts to make who will be laughing that
me still but yeah but that's so funny
Jeffrey classic Jeffrey you know I mean
Jeffrey's the one who's really living
large she does all the work by the way
you know Jeffrey is like a really
prestigious professor at Yale okay like
so he's teaching classes over zoom right
now she's doing all the work she's
probably bringing him baked goods while
he's on zoom like waving to the great
because he's living real life Riley and
she's doing all the work no I mean
literally I was actually thinking the
other day like being I know Gardens like
nice remember that girl Phoebe who used
to come on the show and like the air
nice no because I don't really watch her
like I don't watch Food Network she's
not really on the Food Network anymore
like her life is also really confusing
like she's so rich but like how I feel
like she was rich before
she'd like a very popular show on Food
Network but I think that's it
well like and her show was always about
like her being rich and dancing right so
it's like did you what came first the
chicken oh yeah yeah but then it's like
most Food Network people like to go into
restaurants Bobby Flay Guy Fieri like
they don't stop working except they have
a million different shows and like to
her she had Barefoot Contessa I don't
even know if they make new episodes
anymore cuz I have a bunch of Food
Network in a minute
and by the way the Food Network I
actually thought about the other day
their strategies went like from Giada De
Laurentiis and like Rachael Ray like
cooking shows to like only competition
shows like guys groceries games worst
cooks in America and it's annoying I
used to love like the Giada vibe you
know maybe I should watch some Food
Network now that my chefs like maybe
I'll get inspired
speaking of Chef oh my god did you bring
me Bolognese I didn't because like I
wanted leftovers for myself but I will
make it for you
it is I couldn't believe it and not
gonna lie I didn't look up a recipe
Ben's mom makes the best Bolognese I
always asked her what's in and like she
tells me but I forget so I went to the
grocery store yesterday and I I tried to
remember what she said was in it like
shallot tomato paste and I don't
understand the difference between canned
tomatoes and tomato paste
oh they're really different I discovered
when I was doing my chili yeah so yeah I
just really I bawled it and I was shook
that it was actually delicious Ben said
it was so good so and now I'm like I'm
four days in a row cooking dinner nice
and I loved it and I actually was Sancta
Ben last night as much as I hate
quarantine I'm actually getting into
some really good habits that I probably
never would have gotten into like having
a full kitchen full of like produce
snacks like it's so fulfilling like
before that if I was hungry I had to
order something no I know and I order
dinner every single night but now it's
like I take time I'm off my phone for
like two hours I start making dinner at
6:00 me and Ben eat at 7:00 like we do
the dishes like and then we get into bed
we eat a popsicle me watch a movie like
that is something I hope to take out of
quarantine no quarantine like in the
words of alpha bum I have been [ __ ]
changed for good like now I see it I
want it I'm hungry I make it you know
totally used to be like I see it I want
it I'm hungry I order it like I
literally used to order and I didn't
even realize how ridiculous it wasn't so
much today you know I used to order
avocado toast like for breakfast that's
on the weekends yeah like now I make
avocado toast and it's like I was or I
used to wait 40 minutes because I went
to shop with a soggy avocado toast no
now I have cereal in my house and you
know what I didn't even have before
quarantine both oh you wouldn't imagine
the things I so I I had like four bowls
that were like getting me through my
life like but now I like soup sir now
I've all ordered bowls of all sizes I
have big bowls little bowls salad bowls
I have tiny bowls for all my ingredients
oh so that when I cook I can just start
tossing a mess cute yeah no I had to
order bowls on Amazon because I was
eating cereal out of lumber where I
wonder if we got the same both okay
that's sickening yeah I also had to buy
Tupperware you now I have all these
leftover know what they sell Tupperware
at the grocery store that's okay so I
ordered some Tupperware on Amazon and
then yesterday I was at Whole Foods and
I bought some Tupperware
you know I'm just really becoming so
domesticated and even if after all this
like I don't cook again I would like to
have a full fridge and I used to do
grocery orders once a week for just
drinks and like Wheat Thins like I want
to have like apples like I love opening
my fridge and even though my fridge
smells so bad and that's part of the
reason I never kept food in my fridge
before I hate the smell of a fridge like
with all like the ingredients just like
in your nose sick it's sick and so that
is something I have to deal with now
every time I open the fridge like my
apartments smelling like a meat locker
but it's a small price to pay for just
being so well-fed ya know it's
incredible like definitely I used to
worry about like how I was gonna feed my
children one day like Jackie I think
about that all the time like what was I
gonna make them for dinner not once but
like every single night and you have to
switch it up cuz like kids they need
diversity laughs and now I feel much
better last night I made a grilled
cheese that I only burned one side Wow
it was actually pretty good I think also
the bread is very burnable it's the
Cheesecake Factory bright it was awesome
oh yeah yeah you know they're like
signature brown bread oh well they sell
a loaf of it Wow check it I used to
think about that all the time too like
how I would cook for my kids and when we
were growing up we were on like a
schedule like Monday night was like
barbeque Tuesday tacos once a spaghetti
meatballs Thursday fish Friday Shabbat
and that's five different meals and now
I think I'm at the here am I go to it's
like I can make a mean schnitzel which
kids love schnitzel oh I need to get
there a mean chicken stir-fry which is
nice and healthy with some rice I make
rice as a side dish every night I've
never made rice oh my god you have to
get the minute white rice I've heard
great things
it's a schnitzel chicken stir-fry I can
make now with spaghetti bolognaise and
now that I could do that could you like
pasta noodles butter like I could do a
carbohydrate of sorts tacos I can do now
and now I need to come up with a fifth
one I think it should be like a steak
interesting okay here's what I can do I
can do grilled chicken now
using I can do salmon three four kids
Thank You kids great for the kids the
kids are not gonna be hated it a night
fishies are not gonna be happy on
Tuesday no I'll tell you that Wednesday
I get chilly my kids are gonna be good
eating good chili Thursday I'm sorry
we're having pasta I like mommies and
then Friday I need to learn how to make
like a fancy dish a fancy dish honest a
need to learn how to make like a nice
roast we call it in our house cassoulet
but that's not what it's called that's
the name of the pot that we cook it in
so I don't know why we call it that god
that's what I need to learn next to
cassoulet be where am I gonna get a big
bird during this team if only I lived on
a farm Chema then Zack would have to
like kosher Lee chef them yeah or you
could have an in-house shaft
now that's luxury all surely before we
dive in to the rest of stories I would
just like to point out like that both
Jackie and I but I was really just
talking about myself like I've been
talking left right and center um I mean
I've been talking like left and right a
little bit yeah and I feel like I'm
starting to like act and talk like the
kids on tik-tok cuz they all have like
such cool and they're all like in their
houses and sweatpants like wearing
dainty jewelry and just like looking
fine as hell yeah they're all wearing a
little gold hoops
yeah and that's what I need and so now
that majority sponsors the show I'm like
really turning into like a full-blown
tick tock er I know my my motives are
weird here but just stay with me
Missouri makes fine jewelry for every
day without the ten times markups they
are fairly priced handcrafted and
ethically sourced jewelry they're made
to last that means no more green fingers
or jewelry that oxidizes on your skin
there are 14 carat solid gold staples
that don't wear out or scratch easily
they also come in sterling silver pearls
diamonds and
wedding bands for you or your your man
or your woman or your significant other
and for the men in your life in case you
lost your up and loses his I wouldn't
even realize this actually good idea Ben
loses his wedding band like once every
three months so the next time you lose
is it I'll send them to Missouri because
it's so frustrating one time he actually
dropped it in the subway because he's
always playing with it like when he's
just waiting um Missouri is also now
working from home you can book a digital
one-on-one appointment where you live
chat with the stylist get answers to all
your burning questions how do I style
this can I mix metals what's my size and
so much more head to Missouri dot-com /
toast or use the code toast at checkout
for 10% off your first order
that's MJ you are i.com slash toast for
set 10% off your first order again code
toast at Missouri comm you know look
like the tick-tock er of your dreams
love it okay next story John Mayer okay
this headlines misleading but we're
gonna take what we can get okay John
Mayer breaks his silence about Jessica
simcha
I love you since bombshell memoir oh wow
mm-hmm the 42 year old artist appeared
virtually on watch what happens live on
Wednesday night to chat with his good
friend Andy Cohen during the interview
mayor addressed the book for the first
time during a game of never have I ever
in her memoir Jessica Simpson made
claims about her romance with John Mayer
including that he was obsessed with her
sexually and emotionally addressing the
memoir John Mayer said I've heard about
it I've heard some bits but as pee-wee
Herman says in pee-wee's big adventure
before the movie of his life is about to
play out at the end he's not watching
the movie and the reason he's not
watching the movie he says quote I don't
have to watch it Dottie I lived it and I
think that's prescient here so he's not
saying when she's not saying anything
other than that he's not saying anything
is yes saying that he's not saying
anything but he pretty much pleaded the
fifth but like in different words yeah I
mean I just feel like he must have not
read the book because I feel like if he
did he would have a lot to say yeah and
he's been open about that stuff before
and he's actually not like closed off
about all his relationships whenever
he's asked he answers but most people
don't ask him just Andy does so whenever
he some watch out inside can we get the
good stuff yeah but now that I'm
thinking about it I feel like Andy
didn't read the book either because that
that's not the question you would have
asked if you read the book because the
the og love s oh my god
Jesus Wow okay where would I start I
don't know shoot okay hmm I don't know
no there's so many questions like I
would I would just want to talk about
like specific incidents where like he
was just being a little out of control
like when he was trying to get Jessica
to sing with him even though that was
something that she did with Nick Lachey
and that was like very intimate between
the two of them and she kind of like had
a breakdown soon no but like it was just
it wasn't right or like when she took up
photography to like try and impress him
and like she dyed her hair brown and
then they went into the Met Gala
together they're like I would just look
at they went to the Met Gala together
I'm sorry I didn't look up a photo the
photos are iconic are they oh my god how
did I know they are and I just feel like
the part where he was obsessed with her
sexually and emotionally like just
doesn't even scratch the surface oh my
god hold on give me a minute John
Tamihere Met Gala I'm gonna chuck her
tits how much she did dye her hair brow
timewe they're so cute
yeah and like now when you look back on
those photos you can see how like she
was really trying to like be the girl
that she thought that he wanted in like
this artistic person she's like go to
his shows like take photos like
photographs with a camera it's so funny
how I'm at the Met Gala red-carpet what
like it's not really a thing back then
there's no real red carpet photos of
them they're like walking well I I don't
know that they did the carpet together
but they went they definitely walked
separately because recipes are amazing
yeah I kind of like her with brown hair
I know what an iconic woman I'll put
some pictures on her Instagram so
basically like someone asked him a
question about Jessica Simpson's book
and he spoke words but they weren't an
answer cool I love when people speak
words that don't answer my question it's
actually the most frustrating thing ever
right and that's like a celebrity trait
like is to literally speak so many words
without ever answering the direct
question yeah it's so frustrating it is
frustrating but we'll take what we can
get during these current times have you
watched any of these at home late-night
shows no I literally haven't turned on
cable I've been on my fire stick since
the quarantine started I went off for
Vanderpump rules and I'll probably go
back to cable input 3 tonight for Real
Housewives of New York premiere and
keeping up with the kardashians episode
but for the rest of the weekend I'll be
back on HDMI one for my Amazon fire
stick mm-hmm I feel that have you um I
don't even know
what I'm doing anymore no have you
watched any late night shows oh no no
I'm like not interested I'm barely
interested when they're high tech and
you know Studio 8h and now that they're
just in my living room
honestly the toast is better quality
then half the ship being put on TV right
now so I'm good yeah but also it is cool
that they can pretty much get like any
celebrity to go on a show but it's funny
that Annie still just talks to like
drama yeah yeah exactly okay next up
Kristen Bell says she was told she
wasn't pretty enough early in her career
that's so weird in a recent interview
with Vanity Fair Kristen Bell offered a
timeline of her career revealing that in
its early days she was criticised for
her looks quote I would get feedback
from an audition
well you're not pretty enough to play
the pretty girl but you're not quirky
enough we're weird enough to play the
weird girl she said of her beginning in
show business she didn't know exactly
what to think of such comments I was
like okay so does that just mean I can't
be an actor what does that mean that's
what I was getting feedback on in every
single audition that's so weird because
money you consider her as my first
memory of Kristen Bell was her being the
voice of God of Gossip Girl and to me
like you have to be the coolest most
beautiful woman to like be the voice of
Gossip Girl so I've always regarded her
as like this very like and by the way
she's beautiful so I don't know how you
could say she's not pretty enough to be
the main star because there people have
been in movies who are uglier than her
so I just this makes no sense to me and
I've always regarded her in my mind
that's like a very cool person because
she was the voice of Gossip Girl
yeah I'm trying to before she was the
voice of Gossip Girl though I knew who
she was
so I'm trying oh she was Veronica Mars
you can carry a TV show you can carry a
romantic comedy yeah and then she really
started to like pop off and I think
that's just because people loved her and
so at a certain point you don't need to
like convince some person right like you
when people already like you um I told
you I've been watching so many movies on
Disney Plus last night I watched Cheaper
by the Dozen is such a good movie like I
remember loving it as a kid but it
really holds up like as an adult and do
you know Dax Shepard is it in I might
have your favorite person who does he
play he has a very small role like at
the end when the mom finally comes back
from the book tour and like the whole
world of families falling apart and
she's like listen we will get everything
together but Oprah wants me to come on
Oprah is coming so they clean the house
and Oprah set cut the the tech people
come and all the kids are fighting and
they're like this supposed to be one big
happy family
this is not right we're calling on Oprah
that was Jack Shephard he was the
cameraman got it yeah really really good
movie actually in watching all these old
movies that we're choosing it is
interesting to see like people who are
really big stars now like them in their
smaller beginnings like Octavia Spencer
in dinner first - yes I totally agree I
love seeing like random people who I
didn't even remember we're in rubies
yeah we're like Alyson Stoner Cheaper by
the Dozen oh but how could you forget so
we'll assign toes moving the day but
I've actually been watching stuff I'm
really enjoying and I'll just recommend
like for fun I definitely recommend the
pacifier and I definitely recommend
Cheaper by the Dozen like movies that
really meant a lot to me as a kid and
definitely held up as an adult
nice yeah well okay well our fifth and
final story is a little bit of good work
people working together news because the
Patriots playing the Patriots of New
England yeah they're familiar their team
plane is bringing 1.2 million masks to
the United States from China Wow so they
are using the Patriots plane because
there was this whole deal between the
governor of Massachusetts to get these
masks into Massachusetts but they didn't
have a way of getting them there long
story short the papercraft
Patriots logo plane went and got them
and like the pictures are actually
really crazy of all these workers and
hazmat suits loading up millions of
masks onto this Patriots plane that is
so fabulous
Wow I'm telling you this is exactly what
dr. Burke said one of the things that
has been so wonderful to say is both the
Democrats the Republicans and the
private sector coming together to just
help and I'd love to see this I love
businessmen you know just getting
involved yeah I love to see this just
like see it and it really does make you
think it's like kind of like be strong I
feel like Bethenny's setting the
president here it's like we need all
these materials yes and it's great when
people don't eat them but how do we get
them across the world when you read this
I thought you were gonna say something
about Bethenny because this is very much
like the best to be strong method yeah
of just like using the planes in the
hangars to get the mass yeah love it
love it I'd love to see it thanks
everyone who's been stepping up if I did
have a plane I would definitely hook it
up also Bethenny I told you like her
everything that happens for be strong
happens on Twitter and she literally
tweeted out last night and I didn't
check to see what happen she said I need
two celebrities to donate two hundred
fifty thousand dollars each and I wonder
if anyone responded to her did she say
what it was for yeah tell you yeah her
Twitter is like literally a breeding
of charitable philanthropy like it's so
crazy yeah wow that's amazing I really
love this boy let me tell you Bethenny
Frankel's she said I need three
celebrities to accept my challenge to
donate $250,000 to be strong to supply
15 to 20 hospitals each with life-saving
equipment you have all asked how to help
ask the people who inspire you to jump
in and be part of the challenge Wow are
we part of the change no one responded
to her love it no don't love that but
very sad okay I mean or maybe people
responded privately they want to be in a
non that's triggered Ted Danson
maybe it's Ted Danson that's true the
anonymous wing yeah
okay so let's jump do with many of the
other stories before we jump out no we
do not y'all so we're gonna jump into
our TV recap well recap pump roles
because we didn't recap it on Tuesday
and we are going to recap our toes movie
of the day which was Dinner for Schmucks
and we're gonna assign our toast Mo's
night we're not going to recap that
movie we're gonna tear it apart we're
gonna tear it apart limb from limb and
our TV recaps Eggman is brought to you
by hello fresh hello fresh is recipes
are so delicious get mouth-watering
seasonal recipes and pre measured
ingredients delivered right to your door
with Hello fresh America's number one
meal kit they make cooking at home fun
easy and affordable and during the
quarantine I feel like there's nothing
better than we're nothing more pertinent
to the situation than having prepackaged
meals at your house like I have so many
and to be honest there's so much easier
than preparing like a million side
dishes it's just it's too hard like the
way hellofresh prepares it is fabulous
it's fabulous it's what got me my foray
into learning how to cook like went in
the quarantine started I was like using
all my prepackaged hella fresh meal kits
like they were everything of the sort I
was making like these gourmet cuisines
for Zach and like pretending like mrs.
sapphire style that I know that it was
from scratch but he didn't know the
difference because he'll of fresh
ingredients are just of that quality and
there's something for everyone including
low calorie meals vegetarian meals which
is what Jackie got and family friendly
recipes every week so when we have kids
we actually don't need to learn we could
just get the family friendly hello fresh
recipe that's true they have more
five-star recipes than any other meal
kit so you know you're getting something
delicious they cut out stressful meal
planning and prepping so you can enjoy
cooking and get dinner on the table in
just about 30 minutes or even 20 minutes
with some of their quick recipe options
the average trip to the grocery store
takes 41 minutes
hello freshers pre-portion ingredients
means there's less prep for you and less
food waste they're packaging that they
used to ship your food is almost
entirely made from recyclable and or
recycled content their carbon footprint
is 25 percent lower than store-bought
grocery made meals you can add extra
meals or lunches to your weekly order
throw in sides or desserts like garlic
bread or cookie dough you can easily
change your delivery day for food
preferences or skip a week if you're
going out of town or something go to
hello fresh comm slash toasts and use
the code toast for 10 I'm sorry and use
the code toast 10 for 10 free meals
including free shipping now is the
perfect time to sign up for how fresh if
you've been wanting to the link is
hellofresh comm slash toast 10 that's
toas t10 and you'd use the code toas t10
for 10 free meals including free
shipping Thank You hello fresh sign on
eat well okay let's go into pump rules
okay three days ago so I don't fully
remember but my notes were my notes
where as such when Katie called Raquel
to invite her to the wine night and she
didn't even have her number and she was
literally so confused that was so funny
yeah that was so really really shows
like that you know they're trying to
bring the two shows together yeah and
we're just seeing like the growing pains
of that I can't believe they didn't even
have each other's numbers it just goes
to show like how much they really don't
even know each other and like really
even shows like how much more kind of
[ __ ] up it was that they didn't invite
Kristen oh it was beyond having some
girl you don't even have her phone
number no it was like so [ __ ] up
because it's not only like hey I don't
want to hang out with you but it's like
I want you off my show as well yeah and
I definitely think some of the scenes in
pump roles are a little stage but when
sheena called Kristen to be like I don't
want you to see on social media like
Katie's having a wine night like she
really didn't know yeah that was really
sad to watch and when she heard that
like Danica Charlie Raquel like it that
was shocking like it's it was honestly
so beyond strange and I think and Brian
Whalen like mentioned this in his recap
like it was honestly so cruel of Katie
to do that so that went later on in the
episode when she's like crying over
other in justices in the world and it's
like you can't even serve up justice in
your own backyard
yeah Brian Moylan like I think they're
always fabulous but this has happened to
be a really good episode of pump roles
and I was not in the mood to watch it
like when it came on I was just like I'm
in my firestick mode I'm not in the mood
for pump roles but and the episodes have
not been good but I thought this was a
fabulous episode I thought so too and
like honestly coming up
out of the ashes is racquel Livas Oh
1,000% we'll get to that in a minute
okay I totally agree she was the hero of
the episode she's like and every episode
she's just getting stronger and stronger
and like she's she's still like that
dough I'd like little girl but there's
more than there's a little something to
root for now yeah um when sandy bald was
like so [ __ ] ready to TP the house
and shorts was like I'm not gonna go and
max it's just like a weenie he does
whatever he still likes Annabelle was
just like so amped up he's obsessed with
Jax like obsessed he's just he was like
a little too excited it was it was weird
like it's one thing to prank your friend
but like I felt like he had weird
intentions no it was so weird
he's so extra about like his friendship
with Jackson I feel like it's for Jax it
must be so annoying that when like the
cameras are rolling in the Jax's
birthday and he's getting a samurai
sword with Randy's signature and like
tp'ing his house and going so hard and
then like off the show they're barely
friends Jax is like now 40 40 years old
he's like what are you doing ya know by
the way like a birthday present isn't
tp'ing someone's house and I'm sorry
about that episode just did not age well
in this time of corona oh right and
there's a toilet paper shortage and it's
all in Jax's trees ya know wasteful yeah
you might be saying you Fujin aiya
that's wasteful and if they were we're
better friends like if they were better
friends I think that the prank would
have been like better received but it's
like you're barely like even he almost
weren't invited to his wedding like what
are you doing
and he was just so like hopped up to do
it and Tom Schwartz wasn't going so he
still went even though Tom Schwartz
who's like weirdly the moral compass of
that group he didn't go and like Tom
Sandoval couldn't didn't have the
foresight to be like maybe I shouldn't
do this you know yeah whatever I think
Jax like was obviously annoyed about it
but he didn't make it a big deal
no he did it and it wasn't like I feel
like when something is a prank like you
got your prank done in them and when
someone figures it out you're like it
uprating - you don't like have a
airtight alibi why are you ever gonna
tell them that what was you you know so
are they gonna are they gonna like
wonder every day if someone else is
gonna come and TP their house like
because I'm sure they thought it could
have been fans of the show of course
still like at what point were they gonna
tell them like it's not a prank anymore
like now you're actually kind of just
like the analyzing someone's house and
lying about it yeah it was like an
annoying prank for someone to do when
you're really not good friends with the
person and also like or you could
praying someone that you're just like an
acquaintance I'm like okay there they're
not that tight fine but like to do
something has only annoying like there's
no redeeming
quality about keeping someone's house
like it's only a big [ __ ] mess
like no thanks agreed um next up we had
Brett filming his YouTube video with
Sheena and there were so many things I
needed to say about it one he was
talking about how he has so many
subscribers and all the women who follow
him and like he's just been doing it for
years but he completely fails to mention
that he dated Carli bybel who's a huge
youtuber for a really long time and
that's why he has 500,000 subscribers
not because he's turning out premium
workout [ __ ] I didn't know that yeah
okay yeah I didn't know that so he was
like Carly Babu's boyfriend and now he's
has half a million subscribers but he
literally went on his YouTube he gets
like 25,000 views and it makes no sense
but then when scheana was like how many
subscribers do you have he said five
hundred and fifty thousand and as of
Tuesday when I watch the episode he had
five hundred and thirty four so either
he lost subscribers or he lied uh no
yeah he probably lost subscribers or
maybe he was at like five hundred thirty
thousand you would just say five hundred
and fifty thousand you would you would
act he would round up on TV I don't know
if I would you would round up hoping by
the time it airs that you hit it oh
that's true actually that whole scene
was so cringy like him call Sheena
middle-aged oh my god like that a
YouTube video that absolutely nobody
asked for like what was the point of the
video
unclear I just came to know I just
grazed him I'm very unclear like who the
[ __ ] would want to watch that yeah and
like her getting all bent out of shape
because he called her a [ __ ] girl and
like not being mad that he called her
middle age three times like her
priorities are still out of whack that
like middle aged thing was really funny
you know I thought it was funny too I
don't say I thought that whole scene was
like hysterical but I didn't understand
the point of it all
no me neither they're just trying to
make like Vanderpump rules part 2 like
something of the sort yeah um okay now
let's get to the why night where Raquel
showed up looking so cute Rock House
outfits have actually really been
killing it like she's really been
stepping it up because she's not like a
major part of the storyline yet but I
think her outfits are really speaking
for themselves and it was like when she
was talking to Lala like she was just
really holding her own because la like
always looks so fine um and honestly
like Anna and I know you're probably
struggling with the same thing too
because Lala was like so out of control
you know what I'm actually not
struggling with it because like I I
don't feel torn at all like I love Lala
she's my girl
she was completely wrong completely
wrong so me so mean so dismissive so
belittling like no one person is better
than a not
a person and in that instance I now I
understand how like for the past few
years people have been saying well you
think you're better than us and I've
never thought that she's better than I
might just know that she is but I never
thought that like she was acting any
type of way but the way she spoke to our
Kella was like speaking to a human being
that was beneath her not worth her time
and yeah if that is the case if she's
not worth your timing she's beneath you
don't talk to her at all yeah and then
stop like really being so invested in
James I mean if you are a pitbull and
she's a chihuahua like pick on someone
your own size yeah it was so mean
everything she was saying was so
belittling and they weren't even talking
about like the argument they were having
they were just talking about how she
needs to stay in her Lane and like rock
held very much Shay's in her Lane like
she understands she's not a main
character she literally she's best
friends with Charlie at Sur she goes to
her shifts she stays in her Lane yeah
quite plenty but like Lala King Byrne
she's just standing up for herself that
whole scene was so uncomfortable and
honestly I was really disappointed that
nobody like stepped in and like stood up
for Rock Hill and just told well a lot
of Lala to stop and like Stassi laughing
in the corner and then like being in the
interview like Lala is wrong like speak
up like yeah no I was really sad like
Ariana was making faces but like it was
say it was really made even worse by the
fact that everyone was standing around
watching Lala bully Raquel and no one
said anything like it was deeply
uncomfortable there's ten people in the
room like just intervene say stop um
and then Charlie thought that Lala liked
James which I thought was an interesting
take I thought that was hilarious and
you know you know I love Lala so like
she was acting like someone who wasn't
over someone no I think you don't go in
on another girl's boyfriend unless like
there's some something there I
personally know that there's not because
like I know uh in and out I feel but um
it was it was a funny analysis by
Charlie and then the final part of the
episode was after Jax's birthday they
went back to Sanibel and Ariana's house
and like honestly I love Jax but he's
like a little annoying poking fun at
their house like he'd there he's hosting
your after-party like don't make fun of
the furniture for having cat hair on it
like that certain ones house like don't
be rude I hate when people do that but
then the whole Randall organized prank
happened Randall is really like the MVP
right now I know and by the way I
thought that he didn't drink but he was
taking shots at Jax's birthday why did
you think he doesn't drink I just
thought that him in law I didn't drink
oh no I assumed that he drank cuz she
never said that that was something that
they were doing together okay so they
went to sign of all and Ariana's the
police came to take our
Tom it was really like they were high
high paid actors like the props it was
all really good and really believable
but then obviously there was fallout
after that because sin of all didn't
care he thought it was hilarious and
that's the only person he totally got
him Mac and like that made it good
thanks and that made it okay
yeah but Katie and Ariana were all for
Klimt about it for different reasons I
think Katie was all upset because she
was actually like freaked she was one
who got caught the most like she was
honestly more shook about him getting
arrested then Sanibel was yeah she was
just like really she was the one who got
pranked and then when it turned out to
be fake I don't know why she got so
upset but she was like tagging along -
Ariana's thinking when Ariana was saying
like so many people have negative
associations with the police like why
would you do that in this climate it's
kind of tone-deaf and like I would I
would hear her and respect that because
like that makes no sense like the people
like culturally who have a negative
association and negative experience with
police is typically black people and
Ariana's not black and nobody in that
house was black like I didn't understand
who she was speaking for cuz she wasn't
speaking for herself right it made no
sense and I understood what she meant
like quote like ya know empathetically
and also be maybe she was like saying
like we're on the TV show like this is
tone deaf like maybe maybe if it was
just like friends hanging out and we did
a fake arrest like everyone would be
laughing but like maybe it was it was
she was kind of zooming out I'm like
what this looks like
yeah I just think she's like a little
too woke for her own good you know like
it was a harmless prank
yeah I thought it was oh and then Tom
Schwartz like oh my god that was so
random so disturbing they've been so
quiet for so long oh my god like the way
he was talking her and it was like it
was almost as if he was like blackout
drunk like dark particular yeah just
like saying stuff but then and no one
could stop him like tom is literally
trying to Tom santim I was trying to
like physically were shutting him from
no longer talking like and then Katie
just like walking around in her dress
like not knowing what to do with herself
and like not wanting him to like I was
deeply uncomfortable I don't know how
you come back from that because to be
honest like Tom and Katie have been
through a lot of [ __ ] and they've gotten
past it all but to me this is like the
worst like not only are you saying the
most vile things to me you're saying
them in public in front of people on
camera like to me that's grounds for
divorce yeah and she was saying the last
time that this happened was when they
were in Mexico and when they had that
argument like even though Tom Schwartz
was being mean I was kind
on his side saying cuz I decide and they
weren't drunk yeah and I don't really
remember like what would the lead up to
it was but like we flash back to that
scene I agreed that it wasn't the same
yeah and it like this is so much so much
worse yeah it was horrifying to watch
and I wonder what happens next I
accidentally didn't record the next week
preview Oh next week preview oh there's
a lot of drama with Stassi and Beau like
her wanting him to propose and like
tearing up because he's not like not
proposing yet but like I don't know that
he is yeah that's always like the worst
staging a relationship when you're
waiting for your partner to propose and
it's like you're either about to get
married or about to break up yep so true
okay Dinner for Schmucks uh okay look I
don't even know where to begin but I
think what's most important is to begin
that it's worth noting that one of Paul
Rudd's co-workers from the seventh floor
is burger from mechanic you're out
where'd he was all I could think about
and he wasn't even like in the movie at
all except the beginning in the end but
he's burnt and burger is so not a big
wig like oh my god by the way he wasn't
convincing that he would be like nine
floor material at all oh my god I could
not figure it out
okay so Paul Rudd's assistant who's
hazel from 30 rock she's my favorite
actress on monitor she is so funny
she's like think of yourself she's she's
iconic okay and that's where the
compliment end
yep literally that's it except also one
more compliment his apartment was
sickening yeah it was I don't know
it must have been like LA cuz she was
going to San Francisco right couldn't
have been so far it was a fabulous
apartment yeah oh my god I turned it off
last night after Amy squirrel from Bad
teacher shows up in a blonde wig and
he's like this is here's why like I just
I couldn't you go and you call the
police and you get this woman restrained
like she was being an animal like
breaking everything in his apartment
I've said this before on the show I
can't stand movies where everything goes
wrong and just everything was going
wrong at every single turn in like and
he was not doing anything to stop it and
Paul Rudd for the most part was a good
guy like he was a nice guy he had a good
life like he just wanted to be happy he
wasn't a bad guy he didn't deserve all
of it like his life literally falling
apart overnight it was so frustrating to
watch him like lose and lose and lose
like with the lunch and the dinner like
he just kept yeah he wasn't a bad guy
yeah just like yeah what so he wanted to
get promoted like the dinner
it's thing looks like a burying mean but
Steve Carrell didn't even care which
made no sense yeah and I thought maybe
like at the end of it all it would turn
off the - Steve Carell was like this
master manipulator genius who did all
this to me like I don't know cuz then
someone message me no you need to watch
it and then move to watch it again
because then you like see it differently
so it's like oh it's shutter island'
like it's turning everything on its head
I'm like you could not pay me there's
not an amount of money in the world that
you could pay me to watch this movie
again like no never me so angry and it
was an hour and forty minutes and I
swear to god it was six hours oh my god
I mean me so it was just so dumb when
Darla like showed up to the brown gel II
was trying to get her poster and Steve
Carell was so dumb oh my god no it was a
frustrating movie I'm feeling like I'm
at the CVS checkout machine yes I'm
gonna punch something I had to keep
stopping every 20 minutes it was just
and you know it was so frustrating it
was called Dinner for Schmucks and the
whole dinner the whole movie was
surrounded by the dinner and literally
an hour and twenty minutes in we just
got to the dinner I was like get to the
[ __ ] dinner the dinner was really the
best party you know what else was the
best part of the movie like was those
little mice they were so cute like up
when they were in the opening credits
when they were showing his craftsmanship
I could have watched an hour and 40
minutes agree of him taxidermy knows
mice agree they were so cute so cute so
cute oh my god what a terrible [ __ ]
movie and oh my god I was just I was mad
about the time that I took out of my
life and you know I had so much time of
an abundance of time these days and I'm
still mad I don't got that kind of time
awful movie I got awful awful movie oh
my god like and it just it's a it's
shocking to me when like mega stars like
Paul Rudd comedic geniuses like Zach
Galifianakis
Steve Carell kids can get into a room
and make a bad movie no not only like
not a good movie a horrible and the TRO
sheis movie that like hasn't been Merced
at the stakes like you know like a
million wasted I know it's an affront to
comedy it's an affront to filmmaking and
it's a front it's an affront to the art
of acting ever since two days ago I was
act like is always curious what our
toast movie of the day is cuz he like
might watch with me and that's like a
fun thing for us to do and I said it was
Dinner for Schmucks and he was like Oh
have you seen that yet and I was like no
and I was like I'm you and he's like yet
he was just like acting like it was a
normal movie like how do we know I don't
know I
I finished it literally at like 11
o'clock this morning and that I came in
so I'm gonna have to go home and like
see what he felt about the movie like
did he know and not tell you because how
would be [ __ ] up oh my god like I I'm
like I feel like a cartoon character
with steam coming out of my ears
yes it's how angry this movie made me so
for then for this upcoming weekend we've
decided to do something different and
choose something actually good so
because it's the weekend we're not doing
a show tomorrow we're gonna do the
Netflix miniseries unorthodox I watched
it over the weekend I thought it was
fabulous I would love to hear Jackie's
take on it and a lot of people are now
watching it so it's on Netflix it's a
four episode miniseries called
unorthodox about a woman who flees the
treacheries of Orthodox Judaism
her name is st and it's fabulous and she
moves to Berlin so check it out I think
you guys will enjoy it we'll recap it on
Monday a reminder for programming next
week we're gonna be live Monday
Wednesday Friday we are going to start
doing shows every other day until
further notice until things slow down
over here because New York is becoming
such a hotbed yeah it's just everyday
we've been sort of analyzing like where
the city is at where we're at if we can
still come in and like be safe and we're
being extra safe we don't want to not do
shows at all um but we just want to be
careful and limit our exposure so this
is the best solution for now we'll take
it just like we've been taking it now
we'll take it day by day we'll still be
live at noon if things seemed to get
better maybe we'll go back to five days
a week but there are a lot of people who
have been calling for us to stay home
completely yeah which we're not which is
not something that we feel that we need
to do at this point because we are being
so painstakingly cautious about
everything but we do think that it can't
hurt to limit the shows we'll do longer
shows on Monday Wednesday and Friday
we'll have more to talk about and we'll
see how that goes next week so we are
just taking this one day at a time this
is unchartered territory Oh an
unchartered territory for all of us so
please bear with us while we figure this
out we love being a part of your day and
we want to continue to show up in the
studio be able to do that for you so
bear with us have patience
thank you guys for listening to the
morning toast reminder to stay safe stay
inside this weekend and you know do a
zoom happy hour if that's your thing and
thank you for listening to the morning
toast the Millennial morning show where
we go live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we will be live at
noon next week as well we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so that's Spotify iTunes
stitcher
ryuko spots all the places whoever you
listen to podcast find us the morning
toast leave a five-star review about a
beautiful stunning and smart we are and
how we use the correct pronunciation of
Mahoney
we hope you guys have a fabulous weekend
we'll see you on Monday bye stay healthy
stay safe